j'étais blessé que du coup tu passes par
tes besoin de passer par l'antenne pour
dire tu es ressentiment envers moi alors
là où tu avais raison c'est que c'est
vrai que les liens s'étaient distendus
entre nous
et j'ai certainement mes torts et tu me
connais suffisamment pour savoir que
quand je suis un peu
dans quand je suis je suis pas très bien
j'ai tendance à un peu à me renfermer
sur moi-même a pas dire et ne pas dire
vraiment ce qui va pas etc et c'est vrai
que je me suis un peu recroquevillés
chez moi et mon chien sans voir beaucoup
de monde et ces mêmes mes meilleures
amies je les voyais pas beaucoup
mais voilà j'aurais préféré qu'on en
parle directement et tu savais très bien
surtout que mais si je m'étais
recroquevillé c'est aussi parce que je
traversais même si je me plains pas du
tout de ma situation mais je traversais
une situation financière
délicate de mon propre fait prêts quoi
l'âge de les impôts sont tombés dessus
et serrage me plains pas du tout c'est
que j'aurais dû payer en heures en temps
et en heure je n'ai pas fait de coup ya
un rattrapage c'est tout à fait normal
mais comme je travaillais - du coup bas
la situation était plus tendue pour moi
est ce qu'on attend d'un ami évidemment
dans ces moments là c'est qu'un peu
qu'ils vous soutiennent même si c'est
pas pour m'aider en tout cas qui me
cherche à me trouver des solutions pour
que je m'en sorte et je t'avouerai que
benjamin par exemple que je voyais que
je voyais beaucoup moins que toi et qui
lui passent des
traverse une situation financière bien
plus difficile que moi évidemment mille
fois plus difficile par exemple m'a
proposé de m'aider j'ai refusé et m'a
dit si tu veux je te prête de l'argent
alors qu'il en a pas et je me suis dit
quelque part
on compte afin que l'argent qu'il n'a
pas et mathieu qui lui vit bien parce
qu'il travaille beaucoup et ça je
respecte complètement fois là bas mais
ils n'offrent pas de solution et en plus
il y met pas ils mettent pas le au
minimum pour m'en sortir parce qu'il ya
des mois où j'étais vraiment s'en
plaindre du tout les français qui vivent
des situations bien plus difficile
évidemment oublier les mois où j'étais
je vivais avec 5,6 euros je pensais que
des fat je me plains pas du tout c'est
de ma faute intégralement et voilà et du
coup on en est resté là et les seules
fois où je voyais c'était pour jouer au
poker parce qu'on a tous les deux cette
passion du poker et il se trouve que
dans talent est la chance tu as une
chatte de ouf tu gagnes à chaque fois
poker avec moi et du coup tu participais
à aggraver ma dette donc du coup c'est
non seulement je n'avais pas d'argent
mais quand je te voyais en plus tu
participes la creuse et mon trou
financier et à chaque fois qu'on se
quitter tu me le rappeler moyens texto
mise en on est bien d'accord que ma
tante à dette s'élève à temps et je me
suis dit mais c'est quoi ce meilleur ami
qui m'envoie des textos après pour me
dire par écrit que j'ai une fois dedans
alors que je sais pas d'autres
pourraient m'aider ou me dire genre
voilà je vais t'aider on trouvera une
solution apportée cas pas forcément me
donnant largement mais dans un pays où
je serai pas voulu parce que le poker
c'est le poker g et k pas joué donc
voilà j'ai perdu j'ai perdu c'est pas un
souci mais tu me l'as pareil tu m'as
paraît que la mef
verbalement l'argent tu ne dis pas mais
à chaque fois qu'on se voyait tu me
disais tu oublies park town d'être et à
chaque fois du coup ça mettait une
pression et du coup c'est vrai que
j'avais de moins en moins envie de te
voir fait besoin de te voir parce que je
me dis qu'à chaque fois je vais le voir
il va me rappeler que je perds de
l'argent j'avais déjà des créanciers
autour de moi non je vois pas mon
meilleur ami pour qu'il dise au japon
rappelle et creuse un peu plus la tombe
donc voilà l'un dans l'autre c'est vrai
que les liens se sont distendus mais je
le regrette parce que tu sais très bien
qu avec toi ont passé des moments
fantastiques sert de complicité de ouf
cirque on se raconte nos vies nos amours
nos peines nos ambitions
ont regardé des matches pas les matchs
de foot et on se cale et les grands prix
de formule 1 etc ont passé les vraiment
ensemble et ces moments là se sont petit
à petit évaporée et je le regrette comme
je pense que tu le regrette aussi parce
qu'on était très très proches et moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on retrouve cette
cette proximité l'un envers l'autre et
pour ça évidemment je voudrais que tu
effaces madame adepte de poker voilà